what well well well it's time for
another video slickly what do you have
to say about your appearance on this
channel so far from a scale to 1 to 10
be as specific as possible about every
single detail go who do you think I am
magneto trap in this plastic prison when
I get free of here I'm going to bypass
your eyes boy you changed man you
[ __ ] change man you used to be better
than that sleepy don't don't look at me
with those sexy eyes it's not gonna work
again I see you all know I love I love
the media you know news media I think is
a wonderful thing
mainstream news media it's the greatest
thing ever it's done it's done me many
great things you know I owe my entire
career that's right slick me I owe my
entire career thanks to media but no one
cares about the media oh really oh no
one cares about the media sleepy okay
what if I told you that your entire
species is a hate symbol
[Applause]
that's right oh now you care now you
care I see how it is slightly I see how
it is as you may know the media has been
trying to find problems with YouTube now
you know they went after me the guy on
top you know
phase to go after the the site itself
seems to be the case
you know the whole ad boycott thing you
know they went on the whole restricted
mode thing it was a big it was a big
thing wasn't it sleeping boy now there's
a new video coming out and it's from
News Channel 10 News Channel 10 my
favorite this is where I go for all my
latest info well the made a report on
YouTube it's amazing I love it so much
keep doing this [ __ ] media because it's
you're giving me content essentially and
sleeping if you weren't outraged before
you will you'll well be now okay here we
go
seemingly innocent videos are making
their way it's already making me laugh
cos I can just tell by looking at these
two that they have no idea what the [ __ ]
YouTube is like this guy does not go to
YouTube okay way into the homes of
families all across the country videos
that are disguised as something else
they're disguised just like PewDiePie
was disguised as a Nazi have you opened
your eyes yeah and so the rest of
YouTube must be in secret disguised as
well news channel tens Mary Coleman
joins us now with more on how easily
accessible they are to children and what
you can do to protect them
can someone please protect that children
[ __ ] you man
I see this from time and time again well
you must protect the children think
about the children only children watch
Peter pastor we got to be careful
it's like bish have you seen my
demographics okay 13 to 17 the smallest
one
18 to 24 25 to 34 65 and Plus what the
wait I have actually people older than
40 watching me what shout out to you
guys what the [ __ ] are you doing with
your life
thousands of YouTube videos or is she
wearing [ __ ] tassels as earrings I'm
sorry I can't take you seriously anymore
containing disturbing and even violent
content in your children may be looking
at those but just as easy as it is to
search for these videos it's as easy to
block them problem-solve
on surface these videos seem innocent
and fun but oh [ __ ]
court to see YouTube Thank You YouTube
for letting us use this clip the worst
part they are being disguised - Lauren
kids and with you two being so popular
that isn't hard and the parents are
actually come what was that what was
that thumbnail play completely oblivious
to it most of the time because they're
either far away from the child or the
child has headphones on and they're kind
of doing their own thing and they don't
realize that the child is actually
watching something really inappropriate
so we can't use YouTube as a babysitter
yes you can there's an app called
YouTube kids it has a very strict
guidelines on what's allowed on YouTube
kids just download YouTube kids app you
don't need restriction mode just
download the YouTube kids app and shut
the [ __ ] up honestly it was made for
parents you have free entertainment to
watch there it's unclear why those
posting these videos are doing it but
there are a few things you can do to
avoid your children being exposed to
them you have the parental exclusions
set up in YouTube you can do that
directly on their website and what that
does is it excludes more adult Andrew
Brant all-star computer service what
that [ __ ] is that they just went to a
computer service shop why you need to
make sure that your kids are watching
Disney video
what's with the god-awful earrings I'm
sorry they bothers me that more than
this whole report at this point YouTube
also has a specific kids app another
option for safety even to know about it
so that you only set up your YouTube
access maybe while you're home or
certain times of the evening things like
that for a step-by-step guide to putting
these blocks in place visit newsChannel
10.com reporting in Amarillo Mary
Coleman News Channel 10 it's
because these channels exist as some
sort of Disney content it's basically
like the Chinese knockoff of Disney
that's just made it huge on YouTube it's
frozen Elsa not copyrighted like why
aren't they striking these videos I
don't understand Disney you need to get
on there I never tried restricted mode
I'm really curious let's see how many of
my own videos I can watch oh where did
they go yes Elsa Vidya what the [ __ ] did
someone actually screen it and was like
that one is fine all the rest is not
okay but the frozen Elsa one it's okay a
[ __ ] ice breastfeeding in it frozen
Elsa titty it's fine titty is fine
that's gonna be all my [ __ ] content
from now on but you know this video
where I just talk for six minute that's
not okay how do they come to this
conclusion this [ __ ] video has Elsa
spanking in it spanked Elsa but there
must have been some [ __ ] miss flag
you know they must have thought that
this is like a frozen Elsa video like
all those [ __ ] webs and Tiaras and
[ __ ]
there must be something deeper to this
what were the tags in this video frozen
frozen games family-friendly just
comparing the revenue between my can we
save YouTube video and my frozen elsa
video which pretty much have the same
amount of use five times more five times
more on the forbidden Elsa video the
spank Elsa but video
god bless I know I talk a lot about it
and in the joke about family-friendly
it's a joke I don't give a [ __ ] like I'm
gonna keep doing whatever I'm doing
exactly the same even if it does make me
less a drip
I'll find another way to compensate it
you know there's other options so don't
get made it the wrong way but it's like
five times more it's like you do the
exact same amount of effort but you get
five times more but it's not like you're
getting five times more it's like this
is what you should be getting but if you
don't do this you'll get [ __ ] that's
what's happening pretty much it's really
extremely frustrating it's not about the
money it's about what's fair and what's
right at least if you ask me okay listen
if all my videos were at this bar and
that's how it is I would happily accept
it I wouldn't give a [ __ ] but it's just
not fair something is currently [ __ ]
with the system and they're speaking of
which all my videos now are frozen Elsa
videos I am making my frozen Elsa video
right now it's happening right now
Moffat calm the best free girl games
online well what if I'm a [ __ ] man
did you just assume my gender
family-friendly feelings
ah friendly barely
[Music]
it's my favorite family-friendly game
what should I slap her where the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] wrecked that [ __ ] family
friendly who's family friendly
I'm family friendly [ __ ] parents are
being warned about a pastime
traditionally seen as innocent news
channel tens Marie Coleman joins us now
with more on us more vowing children to
watch YouTube should be aware of
seemingly harmless youtubers seemingly
harvests harmless but have you heard
about pootie pie I heard that he's a
Nazi I don't want my kids watching no
Nazi I don't even want kids to watch me
alright like I'm not clearly not I'm not
I think I used to but I don't cater to
kids like it's not what I do alright
guys hope you enjoyed that video if you
enjoyed it always I like it's
appreciated whatever you want to do
check out another video and just thanks
for watching I'll see you tomorrow with
another one and as always I guess I
don't really always do it but you know
sometimes I feel a little extra you know
this one is just just for the kids
alright if you're an adult
don't brofist right now not like [ __ ]
adults would do it anyway
jesus [ __ ] christ